[Musique]
je cherche un
millionnaire un PIP chic qui voudrait
bien de moi au moins une fois par mois
je cherche un
millionnaire qui me dirait froidement
tout ce que j'ai est à toi je cherche un
millionnaire
pour avoir des trucs comme les stars
pour manger des homars je cherche un
millionnaire c'est pour ça que je fais
le
boulevard c'est facile d'être
chic quand on a beaucoup de
fruit c'estes commades des
pâté quand on est é et qu'on a plus rien
à compter je cherche un
[Musique]
millionnaire car je sais que ces oiseaux
là veulent placer leurs dollar je
cherche un
millionnaire c'est pour ça que je fais
le
[Musique]
boulevard
mais un très chic
garçon viens près de moi sans
façon il me
baise la
main monsieur écoutez-moi bien moi je
n'y vais pas par quatre chemins je
cherche un
millionnaire un petitp chic qui voudrait
bien de moi au moins une fois par mois
je suis ce
millionnaire qui vous dit froidement
tout ce que j'ai est à toi oh je suis ce
millionnaire vous avez tout du gigolo ah
moi j'ai gagné le groso alors cher
millionnaire je veux bien m'occuper de
ce Grot
oh la jolie voiture oui à la maison mon
petit oui monsieur vous assorprès de moi
oh
[Musique]
embrassez-moi ce gentil
millionnaire a vraiment toutes les
qualités qui peuvent me contenter avec
ce millionnaire
je suis sûr qu'on doit pas
[Musique]
s'embêter téléphone monsieur c'est qui
c'est le commandant du
concordeur allô PAP oui je te reçois
5/ bien
monsieur